So this brings up the issue of what neural nets
are more or less appropriate for. What is the restriction bias,
and the inductive bias of this class of classifiers, and
regression algorithms? So Charles, can you remind us what restriction bias is?
>> Well, restriction bias Tells you something
about the representational power of whatever data structure
it is that you're using. So in this case the network of neurons.
And it tells you the set of hypotheses that you're willing to consider.
>> Right, so if, if the, if there's a great deal of restriction,
then there's lots and lots of different kinds of models that we're just
not even considering. We're, we're restricting our view to just a subset of
those. So In the case of neural nets, what restrictions are we putting?
>> Well,
we started out with a simple perceptron unit, and that
we decided was linear. So we were only considering planes. Then
we move to networks, so that we could do things
like exor, and that allowed us to do more. Then we
started sticking Sigmoids and other arbitrary functions and to nodes
so that we could represent more and more, and you mention
that if you let weights get big and we have
lots of layers and lots of nodes, we can be really,
really complex. So, it seems to me that we
are actually not doing much of a restriction at
all. So let me ask you this then Michael.
What kind of functions can we represent, clearly we can
represent boolean functions, cause we did that. Can we
represent continuous functions? That's, that's a great question to
ask, that's what we should try to figure that
out. So, in the case, as you said, Boolean functions,
we can. If we give ourselves a complex enough
network with enough units, we can basically map all the
different sub components of any Boolean expression to threshold
like units and basically build a circuit that can compute
whatever Boolean function we want. So that one definitely
can happen. So what about continuous functions? So what is
it? What is a continuous function? A continuous function
is one where, as the input changes the output changes
somewhat smoothly, right? There's no jumps in the function like that.
>> Well, there's no discon, there's no discontinuities, that's for sure.
>> Alright, now if we've got a continuous
function that we're trying to model with a neural
network. As long as it's connected, it has
no, no discontinuous jumps to any place in the
space, we can do this with just a single hidden layer. As long as we have enough
hidden units, as long as there's enough units in
that layer. And, essentially one way to think about
that is, if we have enough hidden units, each hidden
unit can worry about one little patch of the function
that, that it needs to model. And they, the patches
get set at the hidden. And at the output layer
they get stitched together. And if you just have that
one layer you can make any function as long as
it's continuous. If it's Arbitrary. We can still represent that
in our neural network. Any mapping from inputs to outputs we
can represent, even if it's discontinuous, just by adding
one more hidden layer, so two total hidden layers.
And that gives us the ability to not just
stitch these patches at their seams, but also to have
big jumps between the patches. So in fact, neural
networks are not very restrictive in terms of their bias
as long as you have a sufficiently complex network
structure, right, so maybe multiple hidden layers and multiple units.
>> So
that worries me a little bit Michael, because it means that we're almost
certainly going to overfit, right? We're
going to have arbitrarily complicated neural networks and
we can represent anything we want to. Including all of the noise that's
represented in our training set. So, how are we going to avoid doing that?
>> Excellent question. So, it seems like there's, there
is exactly that worry. But, it is the case
though, that when we train neural networks, we typically
give them some bounded number of hidden units and
we give them some bounded number of layers. And so, it's
not like any fixed network can actually capture any arbitrary function. So
any fixed network can only capture whatever it can capture, which
is a smaller set. So going to neural nets in general doesn't
have much restriction. but any given network architecture actually does have
a bit more restriction. So that's one thing, the other is hey,
well we can do with overfitting what we've done the other
times we've had to deal with overfitting. And that's to use ideas
like, cross validation. And we used cross validation to
decide. How many hidden layers to use. We can
use it to decide how many nodes to put in each layer. And we can also use it
to decide when to stop training because the weights
have gotten too large. So, and this is, it's
probably worth pointing this out that this is kind
of a different, different property from the. Other classes
of supervised learning algorithms we've looked at so far. So
in a decision tree, you build up the decision tree, an
you may have over fit, but it is what it is.
In regression, you know, you solve the regression problem, and again
that may have over fit. What's interesting about neural network training
is it's this iterative process that you started out running, and
as it's running, it's actually Errors going down and down and
down. So, in this standard kind of graph, we get the
error on the training set dropping as we increase iterations. It's
doing a better and better job of modeling the training data.
But, in classic style, if you look at the error in
the, in some kind of held-out test set, or maybe in a
cross validation set, you see the error starting out kind of
high and maybe dropping along with this, and at some point
It actually turns around and goes the other way. So here,
even though we're not changing the
network structure itself, we're just continuing
to improve our fit, we actually get this, this pattern that
we've seen before, that the cross validation error can turn around and,
and at this, you know, at this low point, you might have,
you might want to just stop training your network there. The more
you train it, possibly the worse you'll do. And again, that, it's
reflecting this idea that the complexity of the network is not just
in the nodes and the layers, but also in the magnetude of
the weights. Typically what happens in this turnaround point is that some
weights are actually getting larger and larger
and larger. So, just wanted to highlight that
difference between neural net function approximation of what
we see in some of the other algorithms